- Hello, I'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
Welcome to
"The Super Slow Show."
Gav, we've done a lot
of stuff with 6 foot
balloons before.
They're big enough
to fit, like, me
and two pretty much?
Six foot man
in a six foot
balloon.
- Rather large.
- Yeah.
How about we step up
a notch and use balloons
that are too big
to fit in your garden.
These are weather
balloons.
- ( grunts )
- This one has a
16 foot diameter.
16 foot.
This one, 30 foot.
- Ridiculous.
- Yeah.
That'll be bigger
than my house. Probably.
We should probably
try and get two people
in this, at least.
- Okay.
- All right?
I'm thinking a little
treat for this.
I have a surprise.
A little special something?
- Yeah.
- All right.
Let's get them
filling with air.
( music playing )
( leaf blower whirring )
That is sizable.
That is large.
I think I can get in this,
actually without having
to mess about too much.
Well, we don't want
any messing about.
Oh, it's getting
blown away already.
All right, I'll be
the wind protection.
Please stop me
from blowing away.
God, this is always
such an operation.
Dan: Ah, my head!
( laughs )
Do you need
more air?
- Dan: No. Oh, my pants!
- ( laughs )
Every time.
Keep your clothes on.
Dan: I can't.
All right, I'm in.
Now it's your turn.
- ( grunts )
- ( chuckles )
Gav: Ah!
Dan: You're getting
really good at this.
Gav: Practice makes perfect.
- ( popping )
- Oh.
Damn it!
( chuckles )
All right,
where's the hole?
( laughs )
( grunting )
- Nice socks.
- Ah! Ow!
Gav: It's already hot in here.
Dan: Okay we're in.
Next step. Oh!
Oh, a little bit of air.
I want to have
a go at that,
that's not fair.
- ( popping )
- Oh!
( coughing, laughing )
It popped with my head out.
Uh!
Okay.
Lovely stuff.
Dan: Look at that.
Gav: There's much leg hair
in here.
Dan: ( laughs ) Already?
- Gav: Oh, dear.
- Dan: Oh.
That is not nice
for that balloon there.
- Dan: You good?
- Gav: Good.
- Dan: Okay. I'm just gonna
pop it, all right?
- Gav: Go for it.
- Well.
- That was nice.
Yeah.
I'm sad we can't
adequately describe
how unpleasantly
hot it was in there.
Yeah.
- ( popping )
- Dan: Whoa!
Gav: Whoa, goodness.
That was perfect.
The way you're there,
just like...
Like a teapot.
( popping )
- Gav: Oh.(laughs )
- Dan: Oh, wow. Geez.
Gav: That's so surreal looking.
Dan: Amazing.
Gav: That was so instant.
Here we go.
- Uh!
- ( laughs )
- ( splash )
- Gav: It just completely
disappeared.
- ( laughs )
Gav: I think I blinked.
But I did get a freeze frame
in my eyes
of the balloon gone
and you just falling still.
The balloon popped faster
than I thought.
That's quite good.
Well, I forgot,
because I was jumping
onto a balloon,
I forgot that I was jumping
from 5 foot up.
- ( Gav laughs )
- But I absolutely killed
my thighs.
Like, I got my thighs
slapped there.
You're all right.
Just a little five
foot drop.
- Okay, now it's 15.
- Exactly!
It suddenly turned
from a nothing drop
to an,
"Oh, I'm actually 12
foot up going ass first
into a pool."
All right.
Get yourself out.
- Let's have a look
at that, shall we?
- All right.
Dan: So, I sort of tried to,
like, I wasn't really sure
what to do to be honest.
Gav: I don't think
many people are.
I mean, there's a lot
to think about there.
Also, because it's such
a smooth surface and color.
It's like hard to judge
how it is from you.
Dan : Yeah. So I tried
to just land on it butt first
and see what happens.
- ( popping )
- Gav: Oh, and then it pops.
Dan: That popped immediately.
And then,
I'm just sort of floating,
and then I'm like...
- ( Gav laughs )
- "Actually, this is gonna
really hurt."
Like, I actually have
thigh slapper on there.
That killed the thighs.
( splashing )
- ( Gav laughs )
- Dan: Look at your face.
- Eeh!
- It quickly went from
no jump,
like a five foot jump
to a big jump.
I wasn't ready for it.
( splashing )
Gav: Should we watch
the other angle?
Dan: Yeah.
- ( popping )
- Dan: Oh, that's so weird.
Gav: It is weird, isn't it?
You went for the ol'
cross-legged.
Dan:
Well, I couldn't really
think of a better way
to make it so more of me
was hitting the balloon.
And my foot's just attached
to the balloon.
Ah! What a silly life.
( splashing )
Absolutely ridiculous.
Really shows you how
fast the balloon pops
considering I was falling.
- Yeah.
- It popped around me
and it was way quicker
than me.
Yeah, or just
how slow you are.
Yeah, that's true.
Hopefully you enjoyed
all that weather balloon
destruction.
We certainly did.
Feel free to subscribe
to "The Slow Mo Guys"
and we'll see you
in the next episode
of "The Super Slow Show."
- Fancy a swim?
- Yeah, I'm gonna go
for a swim.
All right.
- Dan: Ah.
- ( water splashing )
( exhales )
( music playing )
There was sumo wrestling.
The magnet smash.
The ice sculpture
explosion.
Fruit-stand smash.
Oh, that was really
messy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I wonder...
what's your favorite?